one morning eighteen years ago I stepped
out of a New York City Subway on a
beautiful day in September Sun was warm
and bright the sky was a clear perfect
blue I had my six month old son in one
of those front-facing baby carriers you
know so he could see everything and when
I turned right on 6th Avenue
what he saw was the World Trade Center
on fire
as soon as I realized that this was an
attack the first thing I did without
even really thinking about it was to
take my baby and turn him around in that
carrier I I didn't want him to see what
was going on and I just remember feeling
so grateful that he was still young
enough that I didn't have to tell him
that someone had done this on purpose
9/11 was like crossing a border a
hostile border into dangerous uncharted
territory the world was suddenly in this
terrifying new place and I was in this
place as a new mother I remember my
thoughts kind of ping-ponging around
from how am I ever going to protect this
baby to how am I ever gonna get some
sleep
well my son turned 18 this year along
with millions of other people who were
babies on 9/11 and in that time we have
all crossed into this hostile uncharted
territory of climate breakdown of
endless wars of economic meltdowns of
deep political divisions of the many
crises around the world that I don't
need to list off because they are
blaring at you every single day from
your news feed but there is something
I've learned in these 18 years of
parenting and in my years leading a
global women's rights organization there
is a way to face these big crises in the
world without feeling
overwhelmed and despairing it's simple
and it's powerful it's to think like a
mother but to be clear you don't have to
be a woman or a parents to do this
thinking like a mother is a lens that's
available to everybody
the poet Alexis de veau writes
motherhood is not simply the organic
process of giving birth it's an
understanding of the needs of the world
now it's easy to focus on all of the
obstacles to making this the world we
want greed inequality violence yes there
is all of that but there's also the
option to plant a seed a different seed
and cultivate what you want to see grow
even in the midst of crisis budget from
Iraq understands this he is a house
painter by trade and someone who
believes deeply in equal rights for
women
when Isis invaded northern Iraq where he
lives he worked with a local women's
organization to help build an
underground railroad and escape network
for women's rights activists and LGBT IQ
folks who were targeted with
assassination and when I asked Majid why
he risked his own life to bring people
to safety he said to me if we want a
brighter future we have to build it now
in the dark times so that one day we can
live in the light that's what social
justice work is and that's what mothers
do we act in the present with an idea of
the future that we want to bring about
all of the best ideas seem impossible at
first but just in my lifetime we've seen
the end of apartheid the affirmation
that women's rights are human rights
marriage equality the fall of dictators
who ruled for decades and so much more
all of these things seemed impossible
until people took action to make them
happen and then like almost right away
they seemed inevitable
when I was growing up whether we were
stuck in traffic or or dealing with a
family tragedy my mother would say
something good is gonna happen we just
don't know what it is yet now I will
admit that my brothers and I make fun of
her for this but people ask me all the
time how I deal with the suffering that
I see in my work in in refugee camps and
disaster zones and and I think of my mom
and that seed of possibility that she
planted in me because when you believe
that something good is coming and you're
part of making it happen you start to be
able to see beyond the suffering to how
things could be today there is a new set
of necessary ideas that that seem
impossible but one day will feel
inevitable that we could end violence
against women make war a thing of the
past
learn to live in balance with nature
before it's too late and make sure that
everybody has what they need to thrive
of course being able to picture a future
like this is not the same thing as
knowing what to do to make it come about
but thinking like a mother can help with
that too a few years ago East Africa was
gripped by a famine and women I know
from Somalia walked for days carrying
their hungry children in search of food
and water a quarter of a million people
died and half of them were babies and
toddlers and while this catastrophe
unfolded too much of the world looked
away but a group of women farmers in
Sudan including Fatima Ahmed that's her
holding the corn heard about what was
happening and they pulled together the
extra money that they had from their
harvest and asked me to send it to those
Somali mothers now these farmers could
have decided that they didn't have the
power to act they were barely getting by
themselves some of them they lived
without
electricity without furniture but they
overrode that they did what mothers do
they saw themselves as the solution and
they took action you do it all the time
if you have kids you make major
decisions about their healthcare their
education their emotional well-being
even if you are not a doctor or a
teacher or a therapist you recognize
what your child needs and you step up to
provide it the best you can
thinking like a mother means seeing the
whole world through the eyes of those
who are responsible for its most
vulnerable people and we're not used to
thinking of subsistence farmers as
philanthropists but those women were
practicing the root meaning of
philanthropy love for Humanity what's at
the core of thinking like a mother
shouldn't be a surprise it's love
because love is more than just an
emotion it's a capacity a verb and
endlessly renewable resource and not
just in our private lives we recognize
hate in the public sphere right hate
speech hate crimes but not love what is
love in the public sphere
well Cornel West who is not a mother but
thinks like one says it best justice is
what love looks like in public and when
we remember that every policy is an
expression of social values love stands
out as that superstar value the one best
able to account for the most vulnerable
among us and when we position love as a
kind of leading edge in policymaking we
get new answers to fundamental social
questions like what's the economy for
what is our commitment to those in the
path of the hurricane how do we greet
those arriving to our borders when you
think like a mother you prioritize the
needs of the many not the whims of the
few when you think like
mother you don't build a seawall around
beachfront property because that would
divert floodwaters to communities that
are still exposed when you think like a
mother you don't try to prosecute
someone for leaving water for people
crossing the desert because you know
because you know that migration just
like mothering is an act of hope now not
every mother thinks like a mother
when presented with a choice some of us
have made the wrong one hiding behind
weapons or barbed wire or privilege to
deny the rest of the world right
thinking they can see their way to
safety in some kind of armed lifeboat
fueled by racism and xenophobia not
every mother is a role model but all of
us have a choice are we going to jump on
that armed lifeboat or work together to
build a mothership
that can carry everyone you know how to
build that mothership how to repair the
world and ease the suffering think like
a mother thinking like a mother is a
tool we can all use to build the world
we want thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]